[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
levels heute gibt eine tolle torte ich
habe hier eine espresso latte macchiato
harte nuss nougat torte alles mit drin
ich denke nacht bei espresso und nach
der kaffee torte oder vielleicht auch
vorher wird das nächste lieblingsorte
denn er sich espresso mit drin und die
ganzen anderen zutaten die er gerne mag
ich habe die torte an einem tag gebacken
aber falls ihr zeit habt könnt ihr auch
am vortag schon mal die böden backen und
am nächsten tag ist dann die torte
superschnell gemacht ich werde zuerst
einmal starten mit den hasen ausbilden
und zeigt euch da vorne mal die zutaten
für den teig brauche ich sechs eier 300
gramm zucker etwa von links tracks eine
prise salz
hier habe ich 300 milliliter buttermilch
und 300 milliliter sonnenblumenöl 200
gramm hasel ist ein päckchen backpulver
und 350 gramm mehl die haselnüsse habe
ich jetzt schon mal fein gemahlen
mcdrive blender olic abc in der pfanne
und tröstete sie haben damit sie einfach
ein richtig tolles aroma entwickeln
dafür steckt man das aroma ganz toll und
deswegen nehme ich auch immer ganze
mandel ganze haus um ganze mandeln und
mal sie dann selber jetzt nehme ich
schon mal die eier zu lassen sich am
besten auf schlagen wenn sie es immer
warm wird da nämlich immer eier der
größe m
und da kommt jetzt zucker mit dazu das
salz und etwas von dem extrakt fast
natürlich immer aber passt hervorragend
zum plaza was auch immer oleds werden
die eier mit dem zucker etwa 45 minuten
schaumig gerührt
[Musik]
wenn die eier macht ein cremig ist
schade sich die maschine ein bisschen
runter gibt es zwei flüssigkeiten dazu
und hier könnt ihr zum beispiel einen
teil der buttermilch durch einen harmlos
linke austauschen
dann habt ihr das aroma auch noch mal
richtig hervor jetzt kurz eingerührt und
ich habe jetzt auch schon die harten
nüsse also die den herd ausgemacht
manchmal so lecker
mein gott ich wünsche die hasen griechen
richtig gut
leider gibt es noch keine geruchs video
werde ich mit pulver mission sei jetzt
kurz hier und kann dann dass hersteller
wegnehmen und die zutaten hier rein 7
sieg beim club wird gerne mal mit einem
schneebesen und gips vorsichtig unter
gebe ich da noch die haselnüsse mit rein
die sollten jetzt nicht mehr so heiß
sein
die kann man auch gut vorbereiten
stunden noch ein bisschen warm und die
jetzt auch noch kurz unter helfen
[Musik]
warum jetzt habe ich hier schon mal zwei
backformen gerichtet und zwar habe ich
meine 2 back ringe auf 24 cm durchmesser
eingestellt und werden jetzt in zwei
portionen machen weil es einfach sehr
viel teig ist und ich möchte dass die
böden richtig schön gleichmäßig werde
ich mich später vier böden haben
falls sie jetzt nur einen rahmen und
auch nur einen backofen ab dann macht
einfach die hälfte des tages packt ihn
und macht später nochmal die zweite
hälfte
dann fällt er nämlich auch nicht
zusammen durch so auch ziemlich flüssig
der theke jetzt die hälfte es läuft auch
kaum aus ein bisschen das in ein
bisschen das auslaufen aber ansonsten
nicht auf schwäbischer oder fliegen okay
dann haben auch gelernt
schwäbisch für anfänger ich liebe diesen
tag mit buttermilch weil da einfach
total saftig schmeckt und ich finde
diese leichte säure durch demut am end
kommt wirklich sehr gut im teig
und jetzt kann ich die tigers backen
kannst du es mal ganz kurz zeigen mit
wie viel zeit schon ausgelaufen ist also
da sie sich ganz normal ist als so wie
ich ganz normal
aber es ist natürlich so weil ich habe
den bug ring und den auf dem
perforierten backblech und das etwas
sehr gerade das falls sie auf einem
normalen backblech backt geht es nicht
weil es einfach dann komplett aus läuft
weil die backbleche die normalen für den
normalen backofen sind einfach nicht
geratet dem immer so eine leichte
wölbung und dann läuft einfach fast der
ganze tag aus deswegen ist eine gerade
unter fläche ist sehr wichtig und die
werden jetzt so im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 170 grad ober unterhitze für etwa 35
bis 40 minuten gebacken
je nach backofen
die teile sind jetzt noch im backofen
und ich werde jetzt schon mal einen
sirup herstellen und zwar wird es einen
kaffee sirup mit dem später die böden
noch tränke damit einfach der tolle
kaffeegeschmack reinkommt dafür brauche
ich gleich zwei adresse ohne ich habe
hier 50 gramm von rohrzucker
das ist so ein brauner zucker man kann
natürlich auch normalen zucker nehmen
aber der hat ein bisschen mehr geschmack
sollte es presse dass ich raus
[Musik]
richtig gestört dass man daran denkt die
tasse vorhat darzustellen und entweder
muss ja mal den cup holen oder martin
als zwei ist resolut
die kommen jetzt hier mit in den topf
und es wird die zucker espresso mischung
aufgekauft und so ein bisschen
dickflüssig eingekocht
[Musik]
jetzt geht es weiter mit der torte die
taten würden sind alle schon abgekühlt
sie habe ich aus der backform
herausgelöst mit einem back vom messer
und habe sie mit orten säge einmal
halbiert so dass jetzt vier gleichmäßig
dünne tortenböden habe
der zero besitzt auch abgekühlt und
jetzt kann ich bereits die füllung
herstellen und die füllung wird jetzt
eine nuss nougat mascarpone creme
ich zeige euch hier mal die zutaten für
die creme brauche ich 500 gramm
mascarpone 200 gramm sahne 200 gramm
fisch käse zwei esslöffel kalt nespresso
neuen teelöffel salz und 300 gramm
nutella also die süße und der geschmack
kommt jetzt vollkommen vom nutella ihr
könnt natürlich auch eine andere nehmen
aber passt eigentlich von der konsistenz
und vom geschmack eben auch sehr gut
nämlich die mascarpone die kommt in
einer rührschüssel
[Musik]
und sie werden kurz verkürzt damit sie
geschmeidig wird und dann gebe ich ganz
langsam gleich die sahne und den
frischen oder
und sobald die zutaten so ein bisschen
verbunden haben
gebe ich auch ein teller und seiner
partner und auch zwei esslöffel espresso
den könnt ihr natürlich auch weglassen
aber ich finde bei der espresso dort
muss natürlich auf jeden fall mit rein
und dann wird die creme steif geschlagen
[Musik]
jetzt setze ich den ersten boden auf
eine tortenplatte und die torte die
richtig richtig gut
ich habe politik gemacht schmeckt riecht
alles sehr gut hier drin werden die
einzelnen böden immer mit diesem café
zero ein bisschen getränkt und wer
möchte kann hier zum beispiel auch ein
bisschen haselnuss league ahl mit dazu
geben
das bringt dann auch nochmal aroma und
geschmack mit rein und die creme kommt
jetzt in einzelnen dünnen schichten hier
einfach mit rein
[Musik]
mit der restlichen creme bestreichen
jetzt noch die torte von aussieht und
stellt sie dann für etwa drei stunden
[Musik]
die torte ist gut durch gekühlt und ich
habe jetzt hier 200 gramm sahne
aufgeschlagen und ich habs jetzt nicht
ganz steif geschlagen wobei ich sehe
doch schon wissen steigt und zwar habe
ich die mit etwas salat verwirrt und
jetzt werde ich einen teil davon und
einen kleineren teil der funde mit etwas
espresso einfärben und der dritte teil
bleibt hell hier in den etwas größeren
teil gebe ich jetzt einen esslöffel
espresso rein und hier 2 ich möchte
jetzt nämlich dass die torte nicht nur
schmeckt wie latte macchiato
das soll auch so aussehen deshalb ein
bisschen kaffee dadurch wird die creme
auch so ein bisschen wieder weicher was
auch sehr gut ist
[Musik]
und hier in die dunklere creme gebe ich
jetzt gerade noch so eine prise dazu
willst du auch noch ein bisschen dunkel
mit dem markt noch mit dabei die torte
zusammen fertig derweil die creme ist
doch ein bisschen zu fest bei dem ich
nun schlug seine rein
so nehme ich nicht ganz steif sein ein
bisserl cremig gerührt hätte ich
eigentlich eher untypisch findet heute
aber wir wollen jetzt die oberfläche der
torte so gestalten als wäre es denn mit
schaum auf meinem cappuccino oder auf
einem latte macchiato grad menge die ich
geplant habe aus der schüssel am schluss
aus zurück
beim musiksommer 200 gramm plane
reinmachen mist jetzt hoffe ich dass ich
das so hinbekommen wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe
als erstmal mittel heller kriegen sagt
mir dann einfach wie du deinen kaffee
ganz links und dann kannst du so wie
diese diese barista so genau hat sogar
das so hinbekommen kittels wie die
sozial dann mit summe zu begleichen gehe
nur mit einem zahnstocher und ich mich
auch gerne mal ausprobieren
dann kommt jetzt die zwei teller kriegen
schon sagst du nicht was tun kann ich
weiß es 100 gesagt schon sowieso
unregelmäßig
manchmal mache ich es sachen in meinem
kopf aus problem ist dann aus und ein
beispiel ist aber so damit ihre dunkle
meter oder dunkel hält genau und ich
will jetzt so in die mitte vielleicht
noch mit heller
es ist doch immer so genau thema
gleichen muster ein gutes nicht alleine
stehen die ganze torte allein so war
herzlich fiel nach hinten gerne beides
jahr und ist sieht man das in der mitte
durch und dann ist es ein herz aber ich
bin jetzt mal war dann ist man da mal
sind dumpfen rein machen und so der
kaffee durchkommen
den rest ist doch einfach beträge meist
kein abschließender sicher keinen
milchschaum nicht weil sie wirklich also
von hier
nein sieht wirklich gut aus probieren
wir den auch gleich vier kilo später
wenn noch ein paar mal dabei oder beim
treten könnten wir das hinbekommen
ich weiß nicht wie du monates machten
sich stabilisierte ja ich weiß habe ich
in die oberfläche besser wenn kein habt
dann macht es weg bin ich dafür ans
licht wer selber schon großes herz genug
so ist gut das ist halt nur noch sein
jetzt schreiben zimt drauf und für den
rand der torte habe ich noch haselnüsse
gehackt und geröstet die kommen jetzt
noch an den rand und jetzt kann steht
einfach kommen hier nur am rand
standorte ankleben aber nur unten als
ich hätte gerne nur am unteren rand
neben seinem toten winkel wo wir beide
nicht verschenkt verhindern griechen so
lecker deswegen weil die so groß sind
wie diese haselnuss schnitte aus mir
wird noch ein bäcker konditor
aufpassen dass ich meine zunge drin das
will ich mich kurze strecken zu hause
ich habe das bis jetzt nicht getan
drum sag mal was oder des landes falls
sie rauskommen sollte nicht mehr als
sonst
ich bin begeistert ich auch gut gemacht
sauber und dann darf der marke tore
gleich probieren mit einem latte
macchiato dazu oder cappuccino probieren
eine richtige richtig echte tortur wird
ja immer nie eingeladen
[Musik]
schönen vier teigschichten die creme und
dazwischen ist getränkt mit einem café
ich finde sie riecht schon sehr hart und
ich glaube du bist du sehr beneidet
[Musik]
manchester machen lassen spontanbesuch
ich habe gesehen dass ich einfach
hierher das ist ja die nachbarn werden
immer gut versorgt wie freundlich wir
hatten mal nach von ihren freie wohnung
und der hat sich gefreut als wir
weggezogen sind hanna gesagt gott sei
dank geht es jetzt kann ich wieder
aufnehmen
also ich wirklich die ganze woche durch
kunst nicht weil ich keine formel 1 sein
sehr lecker erzählt mir freund schon
soviel gerichtet mit den ganzen kuchen
krümeln sie noch da waren und habe dann
den vier top drauf und die creme
superlecker mal so mittel hoch
effizienten die die mische weg über grad
eben daran gebastelt vergrößern
das fleisch ist ja und so schwer in ihr
soll die torte gar nicht und 100 deko
her auch ziemlich einfach gestaltet hoch
anspruchsvolles also seine sehr hoch
anspruchsvolle torte
vor allem die gestaltung ist natürlich
sehr sehr komplex und er mag hat sie
alles stark in höhe gegeben
ja wirklich super gelungen und falls ihr
jetzt auch lust bekommen habt auch diese
torte dann geht auch sallys - lockt der
etat stets noch mal für euch
ich würde am liebsten immer sagen falls
er lust auf diese torte aufkommt vorbei
auf den cup fehlen aber jetzt seine
standorte immer schon weg
ja genau und der markt darf bestimmt
noch ein stückchen essen und ja damit
hier ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und
einen schönen advent wird am sonntag und
ja alles gute bis dahin war echt cool
dass du beim kauf kommt öfter mal wieder
t
[Musik]